you know what I'm wearing this Santa
suit do I look like a douchebag or one
of those guys who looks like he's
wearing Cologne that came out of a
bottle that shaped like a lighthouse or
a car you know I'm talking about you
know what I'm talking about
grown-ups too so grown-ups 2 is the
sequel to the comedy masterpiece
grown-ups actually it's not a comedy
masterpiece I don't know why I've got a
sequel at all some people enjoy
grown-ups I didn't pitch aside as
another Adam Sandler movie that he's
phoning it in on just to get more money
with a cheap quick unfunny comedy and
now we have grown-ups too that carries
on that tradition again this movie has
Adam Sandler Chris Rock David Spade
Kevin James and most of them are married
to women who are too hot for them to get
in real life which is phonics is that in
the movies right there I was like all
right you address that and then when
their kids start getting into some
adventures and that's yours grown-ups
too are so I thought this movie would be
a complete piece of for the most
part it is but there are a couple of
times I was like alright I'll give you a
props for that potential there's a
difference between potential and reality
ultimately this movie suffers from what
I remember grown-ups one suffering from
I always thought once in theaters like
three years ago that's my reference
which is every scene is an isolated
scene it's like oh here's this scene
this happens for the sake of this joke
and they moved to another scene which
that's the same thing and another scene
in rinse and repeat it's like when
you're really high not that I would know
I've read I've heard and read a book
actually it wasn't my book it was a
friend's book it was a friend of a
friend's book anyhow every moment is an
isolated moment that has nothing to do
with the moment before and will have
nothing to do with the moment to come
that's how this is but for comedy every
moments this isolated joke that really
doesn't feed into anything it's just
it's chopping the jokes not funny which
happens a lot of times in this movie
it's just awkward because you know when
a joke happens there's that beat that's
a reaction shot and really nothing
happens in it it's just a pause that's
there to let you the audience react to
it and it moves on to the next scene so
you're not laughing over the important
information or the setup that happens in
the next thing but it's funny Adam
Sandler Oh be like
and if it has that balls that lets you
laugh it out of your system before the
next scene it works but if it's not
funny it still does have that beat there
for you to laugh at but no one's
laughing it's a lock Rizzo like that
happened a few times in this Myrlie made
it unpleasant in the first scene in this
movies Adam Sandler wakes up to a big
deer in his bedroom and then he starts
yelling like Adam Sandler does and then
the deer stands up on its hind legs and
starts pissing on his face and of course
Adam Sandler doesn't close his mouth or
anything he just flails there because
that's what we need for the comedy he
does that to a couple people and they're
just all chasing this r.kelly moose
around the house what are you thinking
my David Spade has a kid they have that
story arc their kids or I'll trying to
act cool for the other college kids
Taylor Lautner's in the movie and he's a
douche bag college kid there's all these
douchebag college kids shacks in the
movies brothers with the ladies man and
at the end the best part of the movie is
that they have 80s references the movie
was very choppy and it's editing and
it's delivery and in a world where
timing is everything for comedy the
comedy was just off in it made the movie
not funny except for a couple of lines
that were spoken in the movie earlier
goes the first half of this movie is
complete I hate it I will
actually go so far as to say I hate the
first half of this movie second half of
the movie it's like it was directed by a
different person not completely
different because I still absurd
nonsense but the second half of this
movie was more enjoyable in the first
half to the second half of this movie
I'll forget in t-minus a couple days
going to be honest I want to say
grown-ups too is not okay and you won't
remember it in t-minus five minutes so
at that point when you got to open the
rating with it's not okay you got to
call it what it really is grown-ups too
is dog that's right apparently I
averaged down in my solid mathematical
score that is my rating system actually
it's not math it's just my opinion but I
won't recommend the movie to anybody
this is the second time they've dragged
me through these coals and I would like
to thank Andrea Sibyl for making my
youtube banner I said on Twitter
whatever banner I use will give a
shout-out to thank you to the person who
made it so Andrea simple thank you
seriously look at that thing I look like
a maniac I love it so grown-ups - did
you see it did you like it more than
grown-ups one did you like grown-ups why
I'm just wondering about the grown-ups
thing for it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you